so Rob we want to play black ops 3 down
Treyarch fun trip we got to play a bunch
of multiplayer and my biggest question
going into that hands down was how are
they doing movement in black ops 3 what
are they gonna do to continue or change
what advanced warfare did with those
exosuits
starting this way and that mobility was
a huge thing in that game and lo and
behold they got this new traversal
system right if I were to say anything
it is very similar to advanced warfare
but a little bit more toned down and
advanced warfare is all about sort of
darted and like very short contained
movements but I think black ops 3 is a
lot about your flow through the map so
for example the double jump you don't
just like jump and jump again with one
charge you have this energy meter and so
you can like jump and like feather it
down to go over here or you can jump up
and like zag this way and like sort of
change your direction or you could even
jump and like kind of hover a little bit
right so that's the the thrust jump is
omnidirectional the idea is that you're
sort of it allows you to change your
direction and flow through the level and
the power slide is another move it is
that's a little bit more direct and a
little bit more dashi in the way of an
event or right get into a controlled
slide and turn to the right and you know
get around a corner and surprise a guy
with a move in that respect
you can initiate the power slide like
mid jump and then you know you hold it
down you trigger it and then when you
land you know it you're gonna slide in
the direction you were looking being
able to control your gun have your gun
up at all times is like the overriding
or the overarching philosophy for this
traversal system especially with just
the whole new the way they've handled
mantling mantling right no longer are
you running up to a window and tapping a
you happy to get your initial jump but
as long as you're just in you know
looking in the direction of your goal
you just kind of flow through so
automatically are you know mantling over
a windowsill or an object or ledge it's
all very fluid and it felt really great
and now you can even run backwards and
shoot which is huge like you're
constantly being able to move around in
Traverse in a fluid manner and as you
said your guns always up during the
process yeah if you are tracking
backwards and you happen to hit a wall
or something you will automatically
mantle over it if you're going forward
and you're mantling your gun is always
up it's not that like let me put my
hands down glamour glamour okay let me
pull up a gun again so it's all with the
idea of this sort of fluidity and that
plays into the wall run block up three
has wall running so but you can you know
you have to come out at an angle as in
titanfall and you know it's less though
it feels less dependent on your momentum
per se because you can go and then turn
around and tap the button and then
you'll be wall running to bat like that
in another direction so it still has
more control I would say than titanfall
so it sort of puts on the spectrum black
ops 3 is movement in between the
abruptness and sort of darting moves of
advanced warfare and the fluidity and
kind of flow based stuff of titanfall
yeah oh also you can swim great
so that's traversal but what black ops 3
is really packing for us is specialists
dude there's like you this is like a
hero character now you've got to choose
one so instead of like in multiplayer
instead of just like I'm you still do
your gun stuff you know you get you get
your gun kit and now you can have up to
like five attachments this time plus an
optic like there's that whole gunsmith
stuff you can even like paint the sides
of your gun and whatnot but in addition
to making that choice your loadout
choice you've got to choose a specialist
and these are they're basically heroes
lady they have special powers yeah so
there's gonna be nine of them we got to
play as four different ones and just to
give you an example ruin that guide this
like American military dude white guy
with a mohawk to to Bionic arms and
specialist has a weapon and an ability
so you choose the specialist and then
you choose one of those two
so what we're ruining ruin had his
ability was a overcharge which
essentially was I don't know if did it
affect your your health or your shield I
think it's just a speed food it was just
even I think you just run real quick in
a CTF match like they even said it the
developers were like you're probably
gonna want this character you're gonna
want to ruin ya to grab your flag and
then run his allele to cover it distance
super quick his weapon is these two big
gravity spikes ya look like big glowing
things and he basically does a ground
pound area smash it like it's like a
little leap and then BOOM anyone within
a certain radius is killed and so yeah
you have to choose one of those so when
you choose so they operate on an energy
meter and like the bet that they sort of
mapped it out the loose things it's like
in a match you might gain gain your
energy meter every three minutes but if
you're doing a medium if you're doing
like pretty well and killing people and
getting objectives you might get it
every two minutes so that it's
accelerated by score and yeah like once
you've got it use it because then you're
not accruing to the next usage and
they're based their special powers that
you can use another character Sara she
was this she was an indecision crime
cartel and so she's sort of this like
badass Street woman like just like she
looks super cool and she's got a huge
gun Magnum yeah
one-shot kill yeah it was like the
Golden Gun and that's the Annihilator
yeah yes and then her ability is to
accelerate the rate at which she accrues
scorestreak points and then there was
outrider another character all these
characters by the way have like their
call signs and their official names and
their little bios cuz they don't want to
try to place them in their larger
fiction sure but yes so outriders is a
brazilian woman from the favela and
she's like wears a hood and has this
compound bow that shoots explosive bolts
and also her ability is a radar ping
that just anyone in the area if they get
caught in the ping will just be like a
red sill
wet and that explosive bolt jibs people
straight up it's fine you tagged someone
they are blowing to pieces and there was
one more that we haven't talked about
yet yeah neither man nor woman he's all
machine
he's all robot Reaper Reaper was
definitely a badass so yeah right off
the bat he's got his power weapon which
is an armed minigun but my favorite of
all these is his ability which is glitch
when I first saw it this blade I kind of
felt scared because it is a very scary
ability in which you can rewind your
position 6 seconds so you can just pull
these moves like that are just
terrifying in that like say that you're
doing hard point right where everyone's
in a room trying to fly some King to
Hill moves I can run in probably drop a
grenade and then warp out 6 seconds you
can constantly take out people
it's totally disorienting because yeah
it's strange and I think your point is
well-taken that it's a little scary
because it's very disruptive
so the flow at this point I currently
think and it's in its six second state
it's a little strong like now it's just
in that a manner of like alright let's H
it back maybe took 5 seconds for 4
seconds right like these things can and
will be definitely balanced down
speaking of balancing and tweaking one
tweak they shared with us that's gonna
really hit home for a lot of players is
that knife kill that's right that's huge
they completely eliminated the one-shot
knife kill so completely because if you
take a knife as a secondary weapon then
you'll still get the one-shot don't you
go but you don't it's not the knife is
no longer your default melee it's not
even there it's it's a gun but yeah
which is which is exactly what I'm
saying on like prolonging like just
gameplay in general so instead of
renting the room and you know cuz that
happen to as well like a guy's just
right there in your face like no longer
can you it's now let's separate
ourselves and have try to shine it a
little bit yeah yeah that was great and
that happened so many times oh and it's
still going on and then another dude
comes in the room
you lengthen the one-on-one aspect and I
am all about it so we've got a bunch of
specialists and new superpowers in the
play and we've got a new traversal
system to handle this the multiplayer
matches we played I mean we had a great
time it's shaping up well it feels
distinct from advanced warfare who knows
what the future will bring in the next
couple months we're gonna be seeing more
of this at e3 and of course as the
release date of November 6th approaches
should be interesting should be
interesting
you